[Music]
ha no you took just Lois in my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to my
fourteenth episode of dirty chest tricks
against Sicilian in this episode I am
going to show you one of the surprising
line against classical Sicilian from the
white respective the opening arises
after the following model fo see fie
Knight to f3 d6 d4 C captures d4 Knight
captures d4 Knight to f6 attacking e4
Knight to c3 defending and now the
characteristic classical Sicilian move
Knight to c6 now as per the database
Bishop to g4 and Bishop to c4 are one of
the most popular choice by white and no
wonder your opponent is going to prepare
for that
however few classical Sicilian players
are ready to meet this move namely
Knight to d5 well this line not only
contains lot of tricks but the good
point is so far there are only 28 free
day games played with this variation
where I think black has to play very
carefully otherwise he can be literally
outplayed at the opening stage as I have
shown over here black has 4 choices and
amongst them a 6 is one of the most
popular choice however let's start with
other replies and see how dangerous it
can be for the black the first move I
want to consider is very obvious Knight
captures efore grabbing the free porn
but in fact it turns out that this is a
big time disaster as we have firstly
on the table can you guess wife's necks
reply yup it's very obvious night to be
Phi and c7 square is under fire in the
opening stage and unfortunately for
black he can't do anything about it
the second new I want to consider is
night captures D fall which is again a
big positional blunder
the reason is after night captures f6
Jack it doesn't matter however black
recaptures the most obvious choice is G
captures f6 afterwards we can simply
play Queen captures d4 and in many
Sicilian lines White has to sacrifice
the dark square Bishop in order to
achieve this kind of double pawn
structure but in this case not only
white can preserve his bishop pair but
the double pawn structure can become a
big headache later on in the endgame so
once again this is one of the great
position for the white camp the third
and the critical move I want to consider
is Knight captures d5 which is in fact
like by engine however as we will see by
going into the depth white obtained a
very good position in this video the
point behind Knight captures defies
after II kept his defy a Black Knight
takes overnight or move somewhere else
then e 7 spot is a great target for the
white km but that's not the whole point
the big idea is black wants to deliver
this check which in fact Vince the pawn
and it seems like white doesn't have any
compensation for 8 but afterwards next
reply Knight to be fine it is now black
who has to be very careful to not to go
in a vast position just for am I sleep
on okay
black moves the king that obviously
white has a great deal of compensation
so the accurate response goes as follows
Queen to e6 Czech Bishop to e2 and now
Queen to d7 which covers the vital c7
square well that's a good side the
downside is blacks light squared bishop
become extremely bad and it will take a
hell lot of time for black to take that
Queen side pieces ouch
here my recognition is why it should
start with C for controlling the D Phi
square and after a six and Knight to c3
even though white is a pawn down he has
a healthy piece development and on top
there are some nasty tricks looming in
there there are few games in the
database continue with g6 which I think
already a big-time plunder
yup you heard it right it's a big
mistake by black the reason is after
Knight to d5
white is looking for the folk on b6
which in fact gives black a completely
losing position if rook to b8 then
Bishop to c3 is a very strong reply so
the most natural response is Queen to d8
covering the b6 square but now comes
Bishop to e3 and unfortunately there is
no defense on Bishop to b6 what of the
game in the database continues with a6
attacking the knight but first black has
to deal with this Bishop to b6 threat by
white and after Queen to g5 Knight to c7
it is very obvious that black is going
to lose a piece after Knight captures 8
as Queen captures g2 doesn't have any
threat because white can simply parry
this with Bishop to f3 and clearly
emerge with an extra rope
the second movie six looks more obvious
response from a classical Sicilian as it
stopped the night to defy idea by white
however in this case white can simply
target the weak d6 pawn
starting with Castle on the Kings side
after Bishop to e7 Bishop to f4 and
castle on the Kings side white can
simply double up on the D file with
Queen to d2 and followed up with rook to
d1 and as you can see with this pressure
sooner or later
not only white will get the d6 pawn but
in fact his species will remain very
active especially if we compared the
light-square bishop s-- i have attached
a model game in the PGN where white
crushed black within 35 moves so kindly
check it out finally let's check out
what is going on after the movie 6 which
is a natural response in such a scenario
and against this my recommendation is
you should start with Knight captures f6
check when obviously if G captures f6
then black pawn structure will be ruined
down and his King will become more
unsafe so initially black has to capture
with the Queen afterwards our same
thematic operation starting with Knight
to be fire
attacking to sports so black responses
force black has to play Queen to d8 and
now more pressure on d6 with Bishop to
f4 once again black has two choices
engine suggests that black should play
here Knight to e5 however I don't like
this the simple reason is here white has
too many good choices for example one
aggressive lion can draw like this
Queen to d4 attacking the knight
and the point is after the move a six
white even doesn't need to move the
night and he can castle on the queenside
has after pawn captures and Bishop takes
d6 and B fie upon both hah under fire
and this position are quite superior for
the white camp so obviously even though
engine suggests Knight to e5
it is a vast choice for the black so
accordingly most popular choice is to
play ePHI but after these we can simply
drop our Bishop back to e3 and now once
again black has to play a precise move
a6 because if he continued with other
moves such as Bishop to e6 or Bishop to
e7
then after c4 white will create a bind
on the d5 square and that means d6 pawn
will become a weak isolated target in
the black camp okay in 6 what else
Knight to c3 and now black has two
choices the first Bishop to e7 is a kind
of inaccurate as it doesn't contest the
D Phi Square and we know from the past
example that after Knight to defy b6 and
c7 are the juicy hole in the black camp
one of the game in the database
continues with castle on the Kings side
but after Bishop to b6 Queen to d7 the
only thing you have to remember is you
can play this in any order let's say in
this game white plays c3 first after the
move Bishop to d8 planning to get rid of
the D finite with Knight to e7 white can
continue with Bishop to c4 well black
executes his plant with Knight to e7 and
I think this is one of the model game
which highlight how dangerous this
position is for the black has after
Queen to b3 black thinks that he can
exchange some piece
and wriggle out in the endgame so he
continued with night captors defy Bishop
captures defy Bishop captures b6 Queen
captures b6 and now Queen to e7 finally
liberating the light square bishop but
it's too little too late as after castle
on the Kings side still that Bishop
cannot move as b7 pawn hangs in the game
black continue with rook to b8 white
response is very obvious rook to d1
still stopping Bishop to e6 idea as d6
pawn hangs so black has to defend one
more time with rook to d8 which finally
saves all the weak point
but after why it's next reply black and
see his death nil as white simply double
up on the d5 and even though Bishop to
e6 happen on the ball after rook to d1
that d6 pawn is doomed to the death and
in fact this end game is completely
winning for the white camp so
accordingly Bishop to e6 is a logical
response covering the D Phi square but
no issues we are still going to go ahead
with our plan namely Knight to d5
once again black has three choices
amongst them Bishop to e7 is averse
reply because y can simply continue with
Bishop to b6 and by force
getting the rook in the corner so
obviously black is not going to allow
this so Bishop captures defy looks the
obvious response but even after this we
can calmly take this with Queen and
after Bishop to e7 Bishop to c4 castle
on the Kings side and the move c3 sooner
or later we are going to pressurize the
d6 pawn and black can hardly get an
accurate
from this last but not least probably
the most critical response here is Queen
- if I check afterwards we will continue
with c3 Black's idea is now he wants to
capture this night as if you capture
with the Queen then both the Queen will
disappear and at the end the d6 pawn
hide behind the d5 pawn so obviously we
are not going to capture back with the
Queen but instead of that my
recommendation is you should continue
with pawn captures d5 and it doesn't
matter where ever this Knight moves the
next move is
Queen to b3 Knight to B it is covered in
the PGN but the most logical response
here is Knight to e7 trying to put that
Knight actively on the Kings side but
not to worry as Queen to b3
first of all create a thread on the b7
square
well Queen to c7 and RB 8 is covered in
the PGN so let's see most initial
responses by black first of all what
happens after Queen captures defy well
very simple we are going to play Bishop
to c4 and after Queen to c6 Bishop
captures f7 and the King to d8 yup the
material is balanced but black King is
clearly misplaced and that gives a great
advantage to the white camp well
probably the most natural response here
is to play beef i grabbing space on the
Queen side but I think this is an
inaccuracy by black and white can simply
exploit this with them a4 so at the
right time once the rook supported we
are looking at a captures b5 and I like
to show you one of my model game against
a feed a master where black continue
with Knight to f5
attacking on III high response with
Bishop to d2 and now it doesn't matter
whether black continued with Bishop to
e7 or g6 both lead to losing position to
the black camp for example in the game
black played Bishop to e7 I responded
with Bishop to c4 attacking the knight
Knight to h4 looking at g2 which I
simply defended with castle on the Kings
side and now you see the dark side of
playing the move b phi as white is
simply threatening the movie captures b
phi which is in fact not easy to stop in
the game my opponent played be kept to
c4 but after Queen takes Queen takes and
the move rook takes Queen the a6 pawn is
doomed to the death and after that with
accurate play and a one-point advantage
what can easily convert in the full
point that's it guys I hope you enjoy
and like this small surprising line
against classical Sicilian which you
definitely want to consider in the two
now in practice with some careful
research you can use this as a great
surprise weapon and gain lot of points
for an unprepared classical Sicilian
player thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care